so you get the news that everybody has
been praying for hope and longing for
for the past 88 days how do you begin to
prepare to bring her home what's the
first thing you want to do for her what
do you start doing guys make her a room
yes make sure she has a beautiful bed
and everything she needs I just the
first thing yeah I thought of was the
comforter the signs in her room
everything and then we went together and
got everything and what are the signs in
the room say um there is a sign in her
room well we did get letters that spell
out her name for her bed and then
there's a sign about hope and to give
her a future in her room one says I love
you on it and just things like that what
about you sue to prepare for the room
what what did you want to make sure that
was in that room butterflies butterflies
I got her function her mom loved
butterflies Jamie loved butterflies
butterflies they have a meaning and new
life new beginning yeah exactly so she
kind of her crystal butterfly big one
for the wall yep Jamie likes butterflies
too what about you Lindsey um the thing
I want to wanted to express to her
immediately and we all do is the pride
we have in her for doing this
forgetting out for making it for the
power that she has you know I mean that
she took the power away from this man
that she did this I mean it's just
incredible
I mean the strength that this little
girl has and the pride that we have in
her for it and that's instantly what I
thought are you all surprised by the
strength because we keep hearing her
described as shy and quiet I am I'm you
are I am i I think there was the power
of God behind it all these people in
this whole nation the prayers that were
said and with
of her her parents her parents are mom
and dad up there I think they made sure
she had the strength the courage to use
that opportune time
I mean how miraculous